this coal being unloaded in the german
town of reinbach is from russia part of
one of the last consignments to germany
before the eu embargo took hold
until recently much of the energy used
in germany came from russian fossil
fuels but now its coal is banned its oil
is soon to follow and far less of its
gas is being piped here than was planned
meaning across the country much of
industry is having to contemplate buying
fossil fuels from elsewhere i think
there will be only a temporal return of
the coal-fired power plants to the
market so this is a no not a long-term
solution this is a solution for the next
three maybe four years which is a
significant contribution to solving the
gas problem or the security of supply
problem
but it is not a sustainable long-term
perspective the difficulty for the
german government is that many of its
leaders have spent much of their
political lives looking to phase out
fossil fuels and yet they now find
themselves having to buy them in on a
short-term basis
we see how dependent we are on energy
imports from all over the world and in
this case especially from russia it's
important to know that we in germany
have technical abilities that are
realistic and produce economically
functioning jobs and economic value
which can help us free ourselves from
this dependency and defend our own
sovereignty
but saying that and doing that are two
different things because very many power
stations and industries have based their
plans on an uninterrupted delivery of
coal and more often gas
such as here at the riders aluminium
foundry in zoltal where rising gas
prices mean managers are having to
change their working practices
starting up a foundry like this heating
up the furnace is very energy intensive
so shutting it down in the evening or
overnight and then heating it up again
in the morning is crazily expensive
that's why we now either run it around
the clock in three shifts or shut it off
completely
the company that runs this power station
decided to get out of a dependency on
russian coal soon after the war in
ukraine began their country took longer
to follow suit but has now done so as it
must be said has the eu
but getting out of a dependence on
russian gas is proving much more
difficult
dominic kane al jazeera berlin